[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'habitude ils reviennent à montréal
pour se reposer entre deux zones de
guerre jamais elle n'aurait pu imaginer
réaliser une mission humanitaire dans
leur propre ville mon père isaac à saraf
32 ans né et grandi à côte des neiges
je suis logisticiens dans l'humanitaire
j'ai fait de l'épidémie de choléra
d'ebola notamment au nord kivu en
centrafrique est plus aussi dans le nord
du nigeria vers de l'actuelle moi c'est
nicolas martel je suis logisticiens pour
médecins sans frontières depuis six ans
j'ai travaillé dans plusieurs épidémies
dont ebola la diphtérie la rougeole et
l'hépatite c en afrique en asie et au
moyen orient pendant les marques fort je
suis médecin omnipraticien et puis
depuis 2002 je fais du travail
humanitaire à temps complet depuis 2013
et j'ai travaillé dans des contextes de
l'épidémie de confirmer et de
déplacements de populations
marc forget a démissionné de médecins
sans frontières
trois mois avant la pandémie de covile
19 l'insécurité saclay c'était mon
quotidien pendant sept ans et en en
revenant montréal je faisais des je
voulais me ressourcer je voulais
travailler dans un milieu plus calme que
les premiers cas sont confirmés à
montréal le médecin s'est inscrit sur le
site je contribue mais elle n'a pas de
réponse
une amie à l'hôpital de verdun le
recruter ça m'a pris de court comme tout
le monde mais après j'ai presque trouvé
ça grise en disant waouh il ya quelque
chose qui se passe puis il faut
s'impliquer et sa mort mon coeur
d'humanitaire s'est remis à battre
le médecin se jouait à la cellule de
crise du sinus du centre sud de montréal
il fait rapidement le tour des ch et
celle des avec isaac à saraf on a une
connivence sens par les rappels de
neuvizy qu'on a fait à verden mois
qu'ils ac
ils ne se connaissent pas mais ils ont
la même expertise et tire les mêmes
conclusions
il faut rapidement isoler les malades de
la convient d' ériger des zones rouges
en scindant physiquement les lieux en
faisant une
aménagement spatiale ou c'est
physiquement impossible de se croiser et
j'aimerais ajouter que de que là dedans
il ya pas seulement les êtres humains et
aussi les déchets la nourriture la
literie les équipements le matériel
toutes ces choses là sont des vecteurs
et il faut des circuits pour pour
assurer qu'il n'y a pas de contamination
croisée
on fait beaucoup de gestion de risque et
c'est un paramètre qui a pas toujours
été prise en compte dans la gestion de
cette crise
est-ce que ça a été la le premier
cherche et se dit vous avez travaillé
isaac et marc ont visité l'institut de
gériatrie de montréal le 25 mars
ils ont tout de suite recommandé de
construire une zone rouge dans
l'amphithéâtre huit jours plus tard elle
n'était toujours pas en place
c'est frustrant il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup de frustration parce que vous
vous savez où vous pensez savoir ce qui
ce qui ce qui va aider et et la mise en
oeuvre est très longue
et quand on est dans l'urgence on peut
on n'a pas ce luxe là pendant qu'on
attendait les autorisations pour
construire des murs et installer des
lavabos le virus a eu le temps de se
propager et vous voyez vous le voyez que
le plus loi qui est l'oeil en a eu huit
sur dix qui vont partir
vous le savez et c'est quelque chose qui
est qui et qui est un peu dure alors
vous n'êtes pas fataliste mais vous êtes
réaliste et vous essayer de faire le
mieux pour ceux qui restent ce que j'ai
trouvé plus difficile c'est une certaine
lourdeur administrative dans la prise de
décision moi j'ai l'habitude dans mon
travail de prendre les décisions et des
rentes opérationnelle la même journée
c'est la prise de décision ici qui est
très décentralisée et dans laquelle il
ya énormément de palier et qui est
souvent réversible alors on fait un pas
en avant deux pas en arrière
ce que j'ai trouvé le plus difficile
c'est de voir comment le manque de
personnel qui a dans le réseau à limiter
les mesures qu'on a pu mettre en place
pour gérer l'éclosion si on attend
d'avoir la solution parfaite
elle n'est plus un rêve de retard
nicolas marcotte a travaillé dans une
quinzaine de ch et celle des quand il
demandait que des zones rouges et des
circuits soit érigée en 24 ou 48 heures
on le regardait avec de gros yeux
je leur ai expliqué les exemples quand
j'ai travaillé dans une épidémie de
diphtérie au bangladesh nos codes doublé
à chaque jour chacha quart contre chaque
journée compte parce que sinon on va
perdre le contrôle rapidement dans
chaque centre où nicolas est passé les
techniciens ont réussi à construire les
zones rouges les circuits les espaces
d'habillage et de déshabillage en deux
jours dès qu'on va en mission d'urgence
il faut bypass et les systèmes un peu et
c'est ce qui a été fait il ya eu des
gens qui ont pris les véhicules qui sont
allés chez réno dépôt chez rona à
shenzhen tailleur aller acheter les
matériaux donc en avait besoin
marc évoluent les partager aussi avec
nos partenaires du réseau en les au chl
des le patron de notre trio
d'humanitaires se compte chanceux
d'avoir pu compter sur eux
c'est sûr que si on avait eu 10 nicolas
marcotte dans les environs on avait fait
tous nos chl des en deux jours peut-être
qu'on aurait type
après moi je suis content de participer
à ça parce que parce que oui c'est vrai
que c'est une tragédie mais il ya
beaucoup de positif qui va sortir de ça
je pense puis les équipes vont être les
équipes médicales en tout cas sont plus
soudés qui l'ont jamais été puis il ya
beaucoup de choses qui va y avoir une
mise à plat qui vont être à faire après
avec comment on peut améliorer le
système et c'est pour moi c'est positif
l'image qui va me rester en tête de
cette épidémie là c'est le quart et la
solidarité que tout le monde a eu dans
le réseau pour faire le plus possible
pour pouvoir ralentir la propagation
dans nos centres ce qui m'a beaucoup
impressionné en arrivant ici c'est que
les équipes sur le terrain autant les
médicaux que les corps techniques se
sont accaparés le projet et c'est ça qui
a fait le succès des opérations ce qui
m'a le plus impressionné c'est
l'engagement du personnel autant les
médecins et les infirmières les préposés
j'ai vu beaucoup de démonstration de
courage et un engagement qui m'ont épaté